When I was on set filming Miss 2059 waiting for a scene to be set up,
I was hanging out with two of my co-stars,
Nikki Soohoo, who played my twin, and Jasmine Batchelor, an African-American woman
who was playing a werewolf alien.
We were kind of like goofing off and talking when Jasmine asked,
"Hey, so what do Asians do when they see each other?"
"What do you mean?"
"Like, earlier today, when I made eye contact with the only other black person on set,
we kind of gave each other .... a nod.
And I was wondering, like, do Asians have anything that they do when they see each other?"
"It's a smile!" *synchronized high pitched giggly laughter*
And to this day, I notice just how much I smile at other Asian people, completely involuntarily.
Whether I make eye contact with them at a party, or at the grocery store, or while driving.
(crash)
I'm just kidding.
But seriously, I do wonder, "Why do I do this?"
Like, what am I actually trying to communicate
with my itty-bitty smile?
"Hello, there. You're Asian. I'm Asian. We're the same!"
"Damn right we are! What up sister from another mister? Do you know if there's any food at this party?"
"Mm-hm, but only that, like, bullshit food, like chips and dip, that everyone already ate. Trust me, I was on that shit like white on rice."
"Speaking of rice, why don't these people ever throw parties with substantial food? Am I right or am I right?"
"Dude, you're so right. Asians know how to party."
"Asians know how to party! Oh shit, I gotta go, I didn't hear what this person's saying at all."
"Chill. Talk later, dude."
But maybe this is just an American thing, right?
Like, if I was living internationally in an Asian country, maybe I wouldn't care because I'm the majority there.
Maybe it would be the exact opposite.
"What are you looking at? You stupid biiiiitch."
"Stupid face, you stupid biiiiiiiiitch."
(dramatic music)
Ultimately, I think it's a sign of familiarity, right?
That kind of acknowledging that you have something in common with this other person.
You know, I wonder if people with the same hair color do this.
(belch)
Or if you're both wearing something from the same fandom.
I know whenever I see someone wearing, like, a t-shirt or hoodie with one of my favorite shows
or one of my favorite characters on it, I'm always inclined to be like, "Heh, nice!"
Even though it makes me feel like a moron, you kind of want to be like: "Hey, I like that too."
"Maybe we can be friends," or, "You're cool."
Wait, what's that?
Did somebody say hats?
Oh my God! Speaking of hats,
This is my limited edition hat available at CrowdMade.com/AnnaAkana for only 10 days.
You can get this hat and other apparel with this really cute neon kitty on it at CrowdMade.com/AnnaAkana
The hat itself is limited, the apparel might be there there longer,
but you can wear it, and then see someone else wearing it, and then be like:
(clicks tongue) Meow.
(music)